thanks to Mack Weldon for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
[Music]
up hey legal eagles it's time to think
like a lawyer because I am on vacation I
have left the craziness that is
Washington DC to try and get a respite
from that but unfortunately the law
follows you everywhere so today we're
gonna take a deep dive into one of the
early 2000s classics shaggy
it wasn't me because believe it or not
this is a wonderful piece of law school
hypothetical waiting to be analyzed and
so we are going to analyze it in
excruciating detail to find out if the
it wasn't me defense actually holds up
if you see an increase in quality today
that's because I have my friend Patrick
Williams who is the director of this
particular video so if things look much
better or much worse than they usually
do it's because of Patrick in fact
there's Patrick right there definitely
check out Patrick's YouTube channel
Patrick H Williams and if not for
Patrick then definitely for his parents
all right so without further ado let's
dig in to Shaggy's it wasn't me we're
actually doing this
Oh
[Music]
so already we have some problems here it
appears that Shaggy and I believe Rick
Rock if that's a real person
are in a situation where one of them has
been caught let's call it red-handed and
they need some legal advice
Rick rock is the one who has gotten
himself in trouble and shaggy is the
reggaeton rapper who is providing the
counsel here which in and of itself is a
big problem because you can't give legal
advice if you're not an attorney already
shaggy here has made some crucial
admissions if I were to represent him I
think that I would counsel him not to
talk to a random friend to talk to a
lawyer and certainly stop making
admissions against interest because if
someone got ahold of this evidence
admission against interest is a hearsay
exception shut the up and talk to an
attorney okay
ignorance is not a defense
[Music]
okay so this may not be a strictly legal
thing that we need to talk about but if
Rick rock is talking about the girl next
door I feel that in a post r.kelly world
we need to question how old this girl is
is she past the age of consent I'm not
sure I actually want to know the answer
to this question because if I know that
there is ongoing criminality going on
then I may have an obligation to turn
that over to the police here and
speaking of our Kelly commentators have
referred to our Kelly's defense as the
shaggy defense in his multiple court
trials this isn't that doesn't even make
sense why would I hold all these women
so yeah that's some terrible stuff to
think about as well
[Music]
[Music]
okay so what my client here has done is
an admission that's not good he has
admitted to giving a key to the woman
who he was cheating on now that being
said obviously that cuts against any
defense of trespass here but just
because you have given your girlfriend a
key to your place doesn't necessarily
mean that she has permission to enter at
all times did she enter during regular
business hours did she come over at a
time late at night when he wouldn't
expect her to be there
does she have cohabitation rights with
this particular apartment or house all
of these are potential things that might
make it let's say illegal for her to be
trespassing in poor Rick Rock's house
she may not have a claim to be able to
legally enter into the premises okay we
have a problem here Rick Rock has
admitted that the only eyewitness to
this alleged infidelity never took her
eyes off of the situation now that's not
great in general direct eyewitness
testimony is not as reliable as you
might necessarily believe often people
forget often things are dark and what
has been shown time and time again is
that actual eyewitness identifications
can be suspect the problem here is that
Rick Rock has identified that this
person knew him beforehand when you have
someone who knows the person in question
direct eyewitness testimony can be very
very good but let's roll the tape back
and take a look at this supposing I
witness testimony
[Music]
it appears that she never got a direct
view of this person she only saw the
back of Rick Rock which means that
perhaps this eyewitness testimony is not
quite as damning as it would first
appear it's entirely plausible that it
in fact was not him except for all the
admissions and stuff so we have a couple
of problems here number one this appears
to be security footage of taken from the
house itself which could be a violation
of the right to privacy if you were to
publicize that we've seen all kinds of
revenge porn cases where you can't use
this kind of footage outside of the home
itself who knows where this this poor
woman got this footage from but it may
not in fact be admissible in court it's
not clear that everyone has consented to
the photographs and photography
themselves and it's unclear where this
is taking place but if this is in fact
in California California is a two-party
consent state which means that everyone
that is being video recorded would have
to consent to that recording being
admissible in court or to being
publicized somewhere else so shaggy is
offering the advice that you have to
convince this woman that night is day
and that never admit we're gonna get to
some other verses here that are even
funnier the bottom line is you get the
legal advice that you pay for and since
Rick Rock has not paid for this legal
advice that is exactly the value of the
legal advice that he's getting here
shut up some of the best advice that you
can give to a client as an attorney is
really just be quiet
stop talking do not talk to the
authorities don't talk to your friends
don't admit any particular liability or
wrongdoing and here Rick Rock is making
the classic mistake of not only talking
to everyone about it but admitting it
over and over and over again but what a
competent lawyer will do is to review
all of the evidence and once again I
have to point out that we have never
seen Rick Rock's face in any of these
potential scenes so if we can in fact
keep his testimony out of this thing
then what we have here is just
circumstantial evidence let's see the
counter the sofa the shower and also on
camera so four different potential
situations when you talk about
circumstantial evidence or at least you
hear it on TV or in the movies it's
always oh this case is going nowhere
because it's just circumstantial
evidence this is some really damning
circumstantial evidence so the fact that
we haven't seen his face on camera
probably doesn't matter all that much
we've seen a person in Rick Rock's house
appear to act as if this is their house
and they're having sex all over the
place and did you know just because you
can't make a positive ID doesn't mean
that this circumstantial evidence isn't
extremely extremely strong and frankly
in general circumstantial evidence tends
to be pretty strong DNA evidence is a
type of circumstantial evidence
so yeah Rick rock is digging himself
into a deeper and deeper legal hole here
let's even get out of it this might have
been the worst verse of all if I were
trying to defend Rick Rock here because
he mentioned not only did this woman see
the entire situation multiple times over
and over and over again including on
camera but she also saw the marks on his
shoulder now why is that legally
significant well at least in cow
fornia and in most states that I'm aware
of part of the discovery process which
is the pretrial procedure how you get
all of the documents and various pieces
of evidence that go into the trial
itself part of that process involves
what's called a medical examination it's
a request for a medical examination so
in the same way that you can request
certain documents in this case you would
obviously request the video camera
footage whether that is in fact
admissible or not but you can also
demand that the court make an order
allowing you to get the medical records
or in fact make a medical examination of
the defendant and in this case if there
are marks on his shoulder from where
this other woman scratched him or bit
him as I'm told
consenting adults can do on occasion the
girlfriend or wife could make a demand
of the court and force Ric rock to stand
for an examination to verify that those
marks are still there
all right let's address the elephant in
the room is Shaggy's recommendation to
claim that it wasn't me over and over
and over again good legal advice
[Music]
I'm of two minds about this it's
obviously not good to go out and talk
about your acts of infidelity at all
it'd be better just to shut up that
being said as a political defense it
might work better than a legal defense
what we have seen at least in this day
and age 15 or 20 years after shaggy
pioneered the it wasn't made offenses
that some politicians who I absolutely
won't name have been able to use this
defense let's say over and over and over
again by doing something and then either
tweeting out or having other members of
this particular political administration
go out and claim that it also wasn't
them and that they didn't do the thing
that they admitted to on camera or tweet
it out but anyway enough about the
administration this is probably not
great legal advice because if for no
other reason it cabins you and boxes you
in into one particular story maybe
there's an affirmative defense other
than it wasn't me he tripped and fell
into the shower or he moonlights as a
yoga instructor and was just helping
this woman a private client obviously
with her flexibility and then having
worked up a sweat in this Bikram yoga
one-on-one session he offered the shower
to to wash off she being new to town
didn't know how to use the shower it was
it's one of those really complicated
like three handle things so he took his
shirt off while he was helping this
woman next door what I'm saying is that
there are other defenses
[Music]
no no no don't don't do that absolutely
do not do that do not admit liability
unless unless we have already gone
through the liability phase he has been
caught he has been found and adjudicated
to have engaged in this adultery then as
a last Hail Mary perhaps you might be
able to get some clemency from the judge
by admitting culpability and taking
responsibility for what you have done
you know I think that this particular
music video is a great example of the
fact that sometimes you don't get to
choose your clients sure it would be
great to deal with innocent people all
the time but the guilty also require
representation as well that's part of
what makes our adversarial system work
in the first place but you know if it
were up to me I probably would not
choose Shaggy or Rick Rock to be my
clients in this particular situation I
think my advice to both of them would be
settled of course I'm not in trial and
in fact I'm on vacation which is why I'm
wearing this incredibly soft polo from
Mac Weldon who I'm thrilled is the
sponsor of this video and what you can't
see but out of frame are the Mac Weldon
shorts in fact here is a clip of me just
walking along the beach in my Mac Weldon
shorts
[Music]
of course what Mac Walden is most known
for are their incredibly comfortable
boxer-brief underwear which I'm wearing
but I can't obviously show you well
actually hold on yeah in fact they're so
comfortable that I can pull them right
off with minimal chafing and scarring as
you probably know Mac Weldon is a men's
essential clothing brand known for its
smart design and premium fabrics I love
all the stuff that I have purchased from
Mac Weldon with my own money it's
incredibly comfortable and it is great
for when you are a lawyer trying to
escape all the craziness in Washington
DC Mac Weldon sells some of the most
comfortable underwear socks shirts
shorts pants you name it it's all great
stuff if you would like to get 20% off
of your first purchase of Mac Weldon go
to the link in the description or go to
Mac Weldon calm and use the promo code
legal eagle at checkout using the URL
really helps out this channel again to
get 20% off your first order of mac well
then go to Mac bald and calm and use the
promo code legal eagle at checkout so do
you agree with my defense of shaggy and
Rick Rock leave your objections in the
comments and check out my other playlist
of other lawyer reactions and other
legal news over here where I will see
you in court